you will never guess what Utah
Republican congressman jason Chaffetz
wants to investigate now this is the guy
who's known as a political investigator
in chief of sorts he was behind many of
the Hillary Clinton Benghazi
investigations the Hillary Clinton email
investigations he's the chairman of the
House Oversight Committee and in the
middle of all the Trump Russia scandals
the ongoing and growing connections and
conflicts involving Trump in the Kremlin
the ongoing and growing conflicts
involving Trump's businesses he has
finally decided to investigate the
Twitter account from the state's Bryce
Canyon National Park right chiefess
reportedly suspects that a months old
tweet posted in December might reveal
that Park officials had advanced notice
that President Obama was planning to
designate over a million acres in Utah
as a mat National Monument and that's
really really suspicious to him it's
hard to understand why this is an
investigation at all never mind why this
is an investigation that's on the radar
of jason Chaffetz although admittedly
it's at the at the bottom of his list
according to him we have no Michael
Flynn investigation we have no Trump
Russia investigation we have no Trump
business conflicts of interest
investigation but a tweet by national
parks jason Chaffetz is going to get to
the bottom of this if Donald Trump was a
Democrat not a Republican Pat the number
of investigations happening right now
would make your head spin endlessly I
honestly think there's some hope for
jason Chaffetz though because remember
recently when Kellyanne Conway was
advertising Ivanka Trump's products yeah
he said we may look into this to see if
she's violating any ethics laws here I
don't think he ended up pursuing that no
you know it's a nice sign right yeah I
thought that it was actually part of the
distraction from what should be an
investigation which is the Trump Rush of
stuff but yes he didn't mention it but
forget about the Russia stuff the Flynn
stuff all that stuff for a second do you
think that Republicans would even have
allowed a Democratic candidate or the
president to not disclose their taxes
with so many reasons to be concerned
about what those taxes contain in fact
we don't even really have to speculate
because Chaffetz boasted that he had
three years of investigations already
lined up for Hillary Clinton if she were
to have one in November I would not be
opposed to Evan McMullen the
conservative independent candidate for
president from Utah primary jason
Chaffetz in Utah it would be interesting
to see this guy is really the bottom of
the barrel true deplorable and I would
love to see a big primary challenge
against them and absolutely because I
don't think Chaffetz is very safe in his
district I mean yes Utah is very
conservative but they're not Trump
Republicans at all now so if he if he
brands himself as quiet kind of close to
the Trump administration not willing to
investigate them they may want to
primary him and judging from his recent
Town Hall's the public is not very happy
with this performance have you been
watching some of those Republican oh
yeah the highlights absolutely we
haven't talked about it much but people
are showing up I actually am well hold
on let me first set it up I don't want
to get ahead of myself a lot of
Republicans are doing town halls and
people are showing up and it's like a
pretty hostile crowd I was watching one
in Arkansas yesterday with Tom cotton
and it was like a 50-50 hostile crowd
and obviously it's a self-selected crowd
these are people who were saying I'm
going to go it's not like the state is
50/50 Democrats and Republicans it
crossed my mind that Republicans are
doing this on purpose just to get this
to get clips of them being shouted down
in media to then maybe fire up their
base or say look at these people who are
just showing up and being so vile with
us or bla bla bla bla bla did cross my
mind I don't know I think the
Republicans are just being guilted into
doing this and what's fascinating to me
is that it seems like even their more
conservative constituents are upset with
the idea that they may try to repeal the
Affordable Care Act and which they seem
to finally be coming around to yeah no
there's no a lot of the complaints that
these town halls are from people who say
do not repeal the Affordable Care Act
Obamacare call it what you will
that's an issue in and of itself and
increasingly we see polling is more and
more positive on the Affordable Care Act
so there's no doubt that that is
absolutely an issue that's important so
anyway jason Chaffetz he's investigating
just the exact opposite of what he
actually should be doing